it's going to be an attacking move this
from Chelsea I'm not now he's lost his
marker Petro go football hey guys Peter
Brown standing in for Nathan Didem UK
freelancer reviewing FIFA 16 with that
note of excitement hanging in the air
allow me a moment of clarity FIFA is an
aggregation of several years worth of
features and modes and all of which are
changed and updated to varying degrees
with each iteration the heart of the
game the way in which FIFA plays
football as for the first time in a few
years made a big jump enough to feel
like a distinct break rather than an
iterative polish last year's slants and
foibles pace over the top three balls
maddening defender behavior have been
taken sternly in hand to the extent that
playing FIFA 16
feels like learning a new game it's hard
and the first few matches are a mixture
of frustration and promise ea sports
latest soccer sim wants players to
compete on a level footing and while
realistically we'll have to wait until
the online population as stress tested
the new system for millions of hours
this is how the change is currently feel
defending is easier or at least
defenders are now better equipped to win
the ball and compete against attacking
players slide tackles have regained some
of the old potency well-timed toe pokes
meanwhile can satisfyingly break up play
while desperate moments give players
more options to deliberately foul
players just before they break into
space this new stronger more flexible
side tackling is a success other
noticeable additions to defending
include tapping buttons to perform a
tackle faint for counter baiting trixie
opponents during one-on-one battles
perhaps most significantly evolve
defender AI has been fine-tuned to make
more interceptions and attract runners
with more doggedness these last points
are the ones that really contribute to
FIFA 16 s most obvious shift the fact
that the midfield is now a battlefield
working the ball through the middle of
the park feels attritional and muddy
full of physicality and friction more
than ever it's a game of inches and
interceptions with defenders urging
themselves towards the ball wherever
possible pressing and lunging and
reaching out feet it can get scrappy
with miss controls and turnovers
spilling messily around for a few
seconds at a time but it feels like an
organic sort of mess a footballing mess
in response to all this there are
offensive tools that make the midfield
an even fight if an asymmetrical one no
touch dribbling adds another layer to
the game's skill system but more
integral is the new precision passing
system which effectively introduces a
hard pinged pass lesser players are more
likely to fumble these stinging passes
and judging ingles ability and distance
as a new dimension to the basics of
FIFA's play for the most part the new
style of play slower grittier but still
skilled seems like it's been achieved
through nurturing rather than nerf first
time
FIFA's success during the last few years
has as much to do with the collecting
and trading compulsions of ultimate team
as it's been about actual football so
the arrival of draft mode a significant
addition to ultimate team is also worth
a good look draft mode sets aside the
main business of buying packs building
teams and playing them against
opposition online it's like a paid entry
one-off Ultimate Team tournament in
which players build a temporary team
position by position opening a pack for
every slot and deciding which player
inside best fist the side under
construction the finished team is then
played against other draft players with
bigger than usual coin rewards for a
winning run draft takes the pleasure of
building a team piecing together strong
chemistry the thrill of opening packs
and gives it to you without the need to
pull your main team apart it cost
fifteen thousand coins or three hundred
microtransaction FIFA points to enter
and of course draft mode is in the end
about making more money but that's ok if
it's something worth paying for and
draft offers something more substantial
than the chance to simply reveal a
randomized selection of players building
a new team is a complex puzzle that's
different with each draft and winning a
few games deliver substantial rewards
FIFA needed a year like this Pro
Evolution Soccer is back in a big way
with PES 2016 and with ultimate team
keeping players playing and paying all
year round
there's been no pressing motivation to
ring the changes annual titles will
always evolve gradually but recent
progress has felt glacial for FIFA the
series can be stubborn and stifling but
it feels gloriously new and having to
learn fresh strategies and nuances in a
game with what feels like a healthier
long-term balance is an almost forgotten
pleasure
right
and he'll have enjoyed that then it you
scored many better the composure to
placing to the left
you